ce ministre la parole est à madame annie
genevard pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
premier ministre
hier matin nous apprenions avec effroi
l'agression au nom de l'état islamique
d'un enseignant en seine saint denis
même s'il enquête a révélé l'invention
des faits par la prétendue victime
la menace est réelle depuis que des
seiches a déclaré officiellement la
guerre à notre école il existe un vrai
problème sécurité des enseignants et
donc des élèves le monde éducatif est
inquiet et attend du concret il faut un
véritable pacte de sécurité dans nos
écoles et à proximité de celle-ci qui
associe chef d'établissement police et
collectivités c'est une priorité absolue
en 2012 déjà
l'islamisme radical s'en était pris à
notre école parce qu'ils étaient juifs
mohamed merah avait froidement assassiné
les enfants et un professeur hors
s'attaquer à l'école n'est pas seulement
un acte de plus contre la france et sa
civilisation s'en prendre aux
enseignants c'est franchir un palier
terrifiant cette attaque est la
transmission du savoir
affranchi de la tutelle religieuse c'est
donc véritablement une emprise totale
que l'état islamique entend exercer sur
la société française par la
radicalisation grandissante d'élèves
dans des écoles musulmanes mal contrôlée
par l'intimidation qui conduit des
professeurs à renoncer à certains
enseignements et aussi par la terreur
qu'inspire ces menaces de mort monsieur
le premier ministre
comment comptez vous protéger l'école de
l'obscurantisme meurtrier de l'état
islamique
merci madame la députée la parole est à
madame là
ministre de l'éducation nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
s'il vous plaît ni genevard c'est donc
en entendu l'agression d'un enseignant
hier dans une école maternelle
d'aubervilliers et est une affabulation
il n'en reste pas moins que la question
de la sécurité dans nos écoles se pose
est un enjeu considérable pour nous et
c'est la raison pour laquelle dès les
jours qui ont suivi les attentats du 13
novembre dernier comme vous le savez
avec le ministre de l'intérieur nous
avons adressé une circulaire précisant à
chaque établissement en france quelles
étaient les mesures qu'il fallait
prendre pour s'assurer d'une part que
les plans de mise en sécurité soit bien
adopté dans l'établissement que chaque
acteur de l'établissement scolaire sache
quelles sont ses missions que l'on
puisse transmettre à la préfecture les
plantes d'établissement au cas où on
serait amené à devoir réagir et surtout
que l'on fasse faire aux élèves un
certain nombre d'exercices de sécurité
de confinement ou d'évacuation qui
doivent avoir été fait d'ici là noël
pour que chacun soit par et le jour venu
s'il ya un malheur devait se produire
cela étant j'insiste sur une chose parce
que votre question posée de questions
d'abord sur les questions de sécurité
nous pouvons toujours faire mieux et
avec le ministre de l'intérieur nous
allons annoncer d'ici deux jours
d'autres mesures notamment pour former
aux premiers secours
un nombre très important d'adultes au
sein des établissements scolaires
mais vous posiez aussi la question de
ces établissements qui disiez vous
échapper à certains enseignements ou
n'osais pas aborder certains sujets
c'est une question que nous avons
beaucoup évoqué au lendemain de charlie
en janvier dernier et je veux vous
rassurer totalement madame la députée
sur le fait que rien n'est mis sous le
tapis s'agissant de ce qui se fait dans
les murs de l'éducation nationale aucun
incident et vous avez pu le constater
par vous-même n'a été traitée à la
légère tous les incidents sont désormais
signalés remontée traiter un suivi est
opéré des référents dans chaque académie
vont dans les établissements où des
problèmes peuvent se poser et les
enseignements sont bel et bien tenue
nous
veillon et la laïcité n'a jamais été
affirmée avec autant de force que par ce
gouvernement dans l'école